dude i had a dream about kevin bacon
speaking of pepperoni how to dream about
kevin bacon bro and i was thinking about
this
so kevin bacon okay first of all named
bacon can you eat can you
can you imagine growing up with the name
bacon as your last name
and thinking that you have a chance to
make it
in hollywood like his journey had to be
harder than anybody's
think who who else you you know
you know what i'm saying where like say
your name's uh
susan carne asada [ __ ] you ain't gonna
be a macgyver
you know you ain't gonna be in uh
dunkirk probably
if you're if your name is um larry uh
poyo con loco bro larry chicken
crazy larry crazy chicken you're not
gonna get it
can you imagine saying my last name is a
meat
and i'm still gonna take life to the
next
level and that challenge
i mean that's you don't see that you
don't see that
you know can you even imagine
can you even imagine that i can't what
if your name is debbie pork
what if your name is d or or [ __ ] uh
you know sergio veale medallions
[ __ ] you lucky to work at the
bank
but kevin bacon said no i got this
you know what if your name is [ __ ]
dorothy pork chop
can you imagine what would you probably
stay at home i wouldn't be
brave enough to go out there with a meat
name
and take that meat to the next level
he's brave man maybe you work at a
kennel
you know what if your name is uh you
know randy beef jerky
[ __ ] you lucky to work at a
chevron
maybe in your later years you get some
uh junior associate work at a kennel
or at a garage but you yeah
the odds are you making it come on man
you can't do that dude to be in the
front lines and be a meat
say man my name's kevin bacon and and
then
overcome the odds gang bruh and he gets
that
he gets that game man i'll honor that
man until the day i'm dead because if i
had a meat name
if i had a f if my name uh
was uh you know rafael
chicharrones or um
or if my name was uh willy shrimp
[ __ ] i'd probably be working by
the ymca
volunteering good evening good afternoon
and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah